to me I think the biggest element of a
personal brand is to tie what you are
doing or trying to do or the job for
which you're applying tying that to
something about your background there
was an African-American student uh who
had not by the way said very much in the
class and we decided to randomly call on
him and he said to you know describe
your brand and he described his brand
very succinctly he had come from a very
poor neighborhood in which there were
enormous Health inequalities and health
adverse Health consequences and he said
you know he said I went to medical
school because I'm a black man and I
want to bring Medical
help I want to bring Medical Care
to to the black community what a
powerful brand a sentence or two which
explains why he's not only that he's
gone to fancy medical schools which he
has and he's now in Sanford business
school which he was but why he was doing
this how he could tie what his mission
was to his own life experience
all right
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
Welcome to the podcast one of the most
popular and influential professors in
the entire country and the author most
recently of seven rules of power
surprising but true advice on how to get
things done and Advance your career from
Stanford University Graduate School of
Business Jeffrey pfeffer welcome Jeff
it's a pleasure to be with you Andrew
it's it's been a delight getting to know
you it's been a delight getting to know
you as well and also learning from you
because holy counted I learned a ton
from this book
foreign
in other words you're trying to tell me
that had you read this book earlier you
would now be president well I would be
more powerful than I am now uh
categorically I can't believe that but
well well so we'll get it we'll get into
the meat of this book
um because it's fascinating but um you
open the book by talking about the
resistance you get toward trying to
teach someone about power that it
somehow seems dirty nasty objectionable
I don't want to know I don't want to
learn and yet this is the most popular
over subscribed course in Stanford so I
know everyone feels like they have to
know and you give a great argument for
why it's like look I don't care about uh
what your motivations are this is still
stuff that you you should learn
um so what what is the argument you make
to the people who think like power like
my even wanting power makes me a bad
person well I think you put your finger
on on why many people object to this
they have seen power used for bad
they've seen bad people use power to do
bad things and so they say I don't want
anything to do with it so it's like you
know if you saw somebody shoot somebody
with a gun you would say well I won't I
don't want anything to do with guns even
though you can use guns for target
practice or hunting or you know for
recreation for all kinds of things and
so I think people confuse how power has
been used with with the necessity for
power in order to get things done so
Stanford Business Schools motto changed
lives change organizations change the
world as you know from your own from
your own experience both in business and
in politics if things were going to
change without influence they would have
already so therefore so therefore if you
are going to make the for instance the
kinds of reforms in the electoral system
that you're interested in or the or the
car or if you want to try to somehow get
people to have guaranteed they basic
income or if you're going to get
anything done you know clean up the
climate or do whatever you want to do
it's going to require influence and
power because that's the necessity of
social life uh ain't that the truth I'll
tell you a funny story Jeff you'll
appreciate this but when I started my
presidential run uh it was called Ubi
2020 in part because I didn't want to
make it about me and then my team was
like yo man you gotta call it Yang 2020
because uh people
so even from a guy who ran for president
like that there was some resistance uh
to to to owning it which is your first
rule is get out of your own way
[Laughter]
and uh you know you talk and and this is
I thought was very very relevant so this
is your fourth book on power give or
take
um and you you mention a critique that I
think some people have which is whether
this is tied up with identity whether
this only applies to let's say uh
straight white men uh or
um uh or is it trying to get everyone to
act like a straight white man or
something like those lines so what do
you mean by get out of your own way well
there are I think a number of aspects of
getting out of your own way I think one
aspect is
um is is being willing to do what it
takes uh to win in a competition so we
just had uh you know the World Cup in
soccer or I guess it may still be going
on and there's a wonderful article by
Sam Borden in the New York Times
um basically about the the U.S men's
soccer team at least at one point being
unwilling uh to in quotes cheat or to do
what many other soccer teams do which is
draw fouls so you know the famous soccer
players Cristiano Ronaldo and you know
all the others Lionel Messi if you touch
them on the on the soccer on the soccer
field they fall down and they roll over
and they act like I think the quote from
the Sam Borden New York Times article is
they turn niggling knocks into Grim
death and the U.S soccer team so the U.S
soccer team said that's not good
sportsmanship you know we should not act
like we've been you know severely
injured if somebody basically just bumps
into us and and try to draw fouls and I
you know I think you need you know you
need to see what your competitors are
doing and you need to be willing to do
what they're willing to do and otherwise
you in the case apparently in the U.S
men's soccer you you disadvantage
yourself and similarly I think for all
professional sports and similarly for
business so you have to I think the
first piece of getting out of your own
way is you have to be willing or at
least entertain the idea of doing what
the competitors are doing and I think a
second dimension of getting out of your
own way is this idea everybody wants to
be liked you know so when you're like in
kindergarten at least when I was in
kindergarten you get grades on
department and gets along well with
others you know and and
um in the words of my friend Gary
loveman who used to run Caesars the
casino company if you want to be like in
a dog a dog will love you
unconditionally your job in the world of
business or in the world of politics is
not to win a popularity contest well
maybe in politics it is to get to get
the most votes but it's it's actually
particularly in business it is to get
something done nobody's hired you to be
the nicest person in the room you've
been hired to execute strategy to
develop a strategy to build product to
sell product you've been you've been
hired to do something and not
necessarily to win a popularity contest
so that doesn't mean you need to be
gratuitously a pain in the butt but it
does mean you need to be clearer about
you know about making things happen and
that's your so that's another dimension
of getting out of your own way well yeah
when you talk about this rule you also
talk about people having these virtue
lessons that if you keep your head down
and do a good job then you'll get
noticed and and that's like uh it's like
a form of character really and you even
been mentioned in the book that this is
something that people of Asian descent
often bring to the table it's like I
don't need to self-promote or I'm bad at
self-promoting I just need to do the
work and that's what you think of uh as
desirable
but that's actually uh only half the
battle let's say and you talk about how
there's performance uh and then there's
um this networking politicking practical
aspect and they're complementary yeah I
mean if you if you do a good job but
nobody notices it's like if a tree falls
in the forest and nobody hears it you
know has it made any sound so so you
certainly need to you need to obviously
to perform and you need to have
technical skills but those skills and
your performance need to be recognized
by your boss or in politics by the
voters somebody has to recognize and see
these virtues and and what you've done
and your boss by the way are the voters
may not be paying attention to you all
the time so it does so it does become
incumbent on you to make sure that
people know who you are what you've done
you know what you've you know what
you're accomplishing yeah this really
was a thing for me uh in transitioning
to become a political candidate Jeff and
my team used to drive them crazy
it drove us all crazy where I I wasn't a
natural self-promoter which is ironic
given that I was running for president
and and there are a lot of people that
uh you know like just assume that if
you're running for office then you're
really into yourself uh you're really
narcissistic
things like that and so when I would
give my initial stump speeches
um I would just talk about facts and the
ideas
um and it took months for me to shift
into doing stuff that was more about me
uh you know and and what's funny is I've
gone through this Arc now several times
when I started Venture for America it
was the same thing where I like started
this org
um and I was like well the orgs idea
speaks for itself
um and then it took my my staff saying
look uh for Venture for America to get
to this level Andrew Yang has to be at
that level so we need to get you out uh
on the conference circuit and it was
when my staff pushed me to do that that
I said okay like I felt like I had
permission because literally they worked
for me and they were like look if we're
going to accomplish our goals you're
gonna have to get out there yeah no
that's exactly right that blue who wrote
this book called
um I'll think of a title in a second
anyway she now runs ancestry.com and
before that was a very senior executive
in Facebook and as an Asian woman and
um I thought the title of her book is
take back your power and she had yeah
and she and she had that same even
though devil well I met you actually
through Deb and she had the same issue
you know I I'm not going to be a
self-promoter whatever and she tells the
story in the book and she tells the
story when she comes to my class of two
projects she ran for Facebook and one
project and they both equaled they were
both equally successful and they were
both financially significant to Facebook
and in the first project she never
really took any credit or told anybody
the story and the problem was her team
all left because they felt you know I
mean the organization did not appreciate
them because they were invisible if you
know and nobody appreciates something
that's invisible so what but she figured
out for the second project was that she
had to tell the story not just for
herself but for the team that when she
did not get any recognition the team did
not get any recognition and and so she
was not just not self-promoting herself
she was not promoting this team of
people who had done this thing that
accounted for 15 of uh Facebook revenue
and nobody knew because though because
she had not told the story so it's
something that you really owe your team
yes and you mentioned in the book and
one thing I I love about your book is
that it's uh
so grounded in research and various
social science studies but you mentioned
that people who are from uh lower
socioeconomic backgrounds
um also struggle sometimes with this uh
self-promotional aspect because they're
more collectivist in bent they're more
about the group and they can actually be
prompted to become more self-promotional
when they're told look like the group
needs you to do this yes that's it and
and of course it's true I mean so you
know you you have you know and it's by
the way been a pleasure to to get to
know you you have a set of ideas and
unfortunately for good or for ill those
ideas tend to be associated with an
individual and so if the individual does
not promulgate uh you know himself or
herself and and and and what they're
trying to accomplish and nobody will
know
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
it's the holiday season it's a great
time it's a terrible time something can
be both
the fact is right now is a great time to
try and process what's going on in your
mind in your thoughts and one great way
to do that is via online therapy therapy
is not like it used to be it used to be
you had to go in person finding someone
was very difficult now you can do all of
that online and better help is the best
way to do so that I've seen as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
with professionally licensed embedded
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with the
therapist and if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Yang that's better our
help
h-e-l-p.com slash yang
[Music]
which leads us to the second rule very
counter-intuitive some people are going
to hate this but number two is to break
the rules uh and when I saw this was
this chapter had I was like Wow uh you
know where is this going and then you
bring in all of these examples around
Norm breaking that if you do break Norms
uh you often get power
um and and I think the single biggest
thing that you reference
um is is this thing is going to make
everyone happy because it's so wholesome
but it's really just asking for help or
asking for stuff is in some ways the
biggest Norm you can break because
everyone's deeply uncomfortable asking
for stuff that is certainly true and the
other point I make in that chapter which
I think is an important one is that
norms and rules tend to favor the people
in power so if you think about the
profound on social changes that have
occurred in the United States I mean
Rosa Parks
broke the norm or maybe the rule or
maybe the law of sitting in the back of
the bus you know the sit-ins and Wars
for as part of the Civil Rights Movement
broke rules about the that African
Americans were not supposed to be at
these lunch counters Martin Luther
King's letter from a Birmingham Jail was
written while he was in jail so he not
only had broken the arm apparently broke
a law Nelson Mandela became the father
of South Africa while he was in prison
so you know I mean if if you are going
to accomplish
social change
um you know you you will you will need a
time not necessarily to go to jail or
whatever but you will certainly need to
challenge the prevailing ethos and by
the way this is true in business
um in a in a different way almost all
successful entrepreneurs I'm sure this
is true of you
see a way to recreate restructure
reformulate products or Industries and
do it in a way that breaks with
conventional wisdom you know so
Southwest Airlines you know issued the
Hub and spoke system and flies point to
point my friend George Zimmer when he
ran the Men's Warehouse you know power
and Retail was always with the buyers
George said my goodness I've realized
one day that you only made money when
you sold it not when you bought it and
therefore we had to put more emphasis on
store operations Whole Foods you know
with John Mackey
um you know had this Insight that people
would pay more for food they wanted to
eat and since tastes vary you know from
Boston to Austin to San Francisco or
even within the San Francisco Bay area
if you would permit
store managers and the Departments
within stores to put to carry the
particular cheeses and meats and cuts of
fish that people uh in that particular
area are from that particular uh social
or ethnic group were more fond of you
could actually have a much more
successful grocery store business
because because you would deliver what
the people uh particularly liked in
their particular tastes in their
particular flavors so so even in
strategy if you want to differentiate
yourself you have to be willing to defy
conventional wisdom well a lot of people
thought it was uh breaking some rule for
me to run for president though it turns
out that there are only two rules to
running for president uh Natural Born
U.S citizen check and 35 years and older
check so there really is no other
um but people would ask me all the time
it's like hey like you know are you
allowed to do this like that there was
like uh that in that case it was like a
a social Norm uh and by the way that was
true for Donald Trump also when Donald
Trump began to run for president that he
he violently he of course his campaign
violates a ton of conventional wisdom
which is one of the reasons why I was
successful in part because people
underestimated him yeah completely of
course I mean he was an energy you know
and Ronald Reagan also these These are
these are entertainers they're not
politicians who've been in politics for
a zillion years you know they're not
following the traditional route of
starting out in the school board and
then the state legislature and then the
national legislature and then Senator
whatever absolutely yeah the the the
third one and I burst out laughing
seeing this the third rules show up in a
powerful fashion and I want to tell you
a story about my poor beleaguered
campaign manager Zach grauman who who
months in
said
um uh dude we need to give you a
makeover we need to give you a new
haircut we need to give you new clothes
like you know new look a new button I
had this uh button that uh like always
was like tilted to the side and no one
it was like supposed to be a why but it
was always on its side
um and and and I resisted this mightily
Jeff because you know I'm an adult man
and I'm like uh so I think my quote to
him was like you know people know what
I'm about like no one cares what I I
look like Bernie Sanders looks like the
professor from Back to the Future No One
Cares uh and he was like no you're wrong
because Bernie is old and you're young
like people judge you different but the
other thing I didn't realize at the time
was that Bernie's look is already a
brand
um and and so it looks like Larry David
yeah yeah or Larry David looks like him
so so Zach takes me to the the shop
and tailors me up and whatnot uh and it
made a big difference
yes so you're not talking strictly about
fashion in a clothing and grooming sense
um you mean a lot of other things in
terms of uh presence uh body language
the type of words you use Etc that 'll
be true but you know after my wife died
my friend Dana Carney who's an expert
actually in body language said Jeffrey
if you're ever going to attract a human
the Bing particularly a woman of the
kind that you want you need to you need
to change her look so she did she did
she did to me a probably much more
expensive version of of what your
campaign manager did for you you know
putting me in you know fancier clothes
that look better Etc I mean we know from
research height affects people's salary
we know that beautiful people actually
do better in part because they're able
uh to build larger social networks uh if
you're physically attractive so all the
stuff that we think maybe shouldn't
matter and maybe it shouldn't in fact
does well one thing you you said that
also
um so familiar I mean as you can tell
I've gone through Journeys and so a lot
of the stuff felt resonant
um but but it was to have a look yeah
and you talked about
um a particular woman who was quite tall
so she wore heels so she was even taller
yeah by the way and by the way she was
an Asian woman and and and of course
Asians are generally seen are expected
to be short and so and so show you that
that was my friend Laura Chao who has
been made partner recently at Canaan
adventures and Laura said many people
remembered her as the tallest Asian they
had ever seen and you know she by the
way has a lot of other elements of her
brand she's obviously extraordinarily
smart but you yeah but you always would
dress very fashionably and you know
because even in the Silicon Valley
context and so you know she looked very
professional and she stood out
foreign
for the holidays this year copy my book
that's one of the things about being an
author is you just give people a signed
copy of your book and you're like happy
holidays so you can do the same thing
mine is my signature just buy my book
and then give it to yourself uh because
it's a good book so check it out board's
out on paperback today happy holidays to
you and yours
[Music]
thank you
yeah so this leads us to number four
which is create a powerful brand uh for
yourself another example you use it's
fun I have personal experience of a lot
of this
um so uh in terms of creating a powerful
or personal brand
um Elizabeth Holmes actually had a very
distinct look uh it was a bit jobsy in
it had like the black turtleneck
um and that sort of thing but the things
that you detail about trying to create a
personal powerful brand
um uh I went I'd gone through many of
them
um which were things around a Blog
conference speaking uh writing a book if
that's uh applicable a lot of behaviors
that end up marking you as an expert in
some way yep and and also to me I think
the biggest element of a personal brand
is to tie what you are doing or trying
to do or the job for which you're
applying tying that to something about
your background so so I you know a good
example with my friend Tristan Walker
Walker and Company brands which was
bought by Procter Gamble uh Tristan is a
African-American man
um who always had trouble
shaving because of the
African-American skin is different and
he would get razor bumps and so double
edged razors didn't work very well and
when he went finally into various drug
stores and and stores he saw that there
was very few of them that had been
designed for people of color either for
men or for women and so what the whole
theory behind Walker and Company brands
was here with someone a Stanford MBA
graduate by the way uh here was someone
who was designing products
for himself
and the people that he knew the people
in his community and and that made him
you know when I talked to Jeff Jordan
the founder of OpenTable it was at that
time working for Andre Andresen Horowitz
he said we like to fund people who when
you look at them you say these people
are uniquely qualified to be to be
driving and building this kind of
company so who is better qualified to
build a company with grooming products
for people of color than someone of
color
you know who is better qualified as also
interesting because Tristan comes to my
class and there was an African-American
student uh who had not by the way said
very much in the class and we decided to
randomly call on him and he said to you
know describe your brand and he
described his brand very succinctly he
had come from a very poor neighborhood
uh in which there were enormous Health
inequalities and health adverse Health
consequences and he said you know he
said I went to medical school because
I'm a black man and I want to bring
Medical
help I want to bring Medical Care
to to the black community what a
powerful brand a sentence or two which
explains why he's not only that has gone
to fancy medical schools which he has
and he's now in Sanford business school
which he was but why he was doing this
how he could tie what his mission was to
his own life experience yeah so I've
heard my brand described as a magical
Asian man from the future who wants to
give everyone money uh so I was like oh
I'll take it
uh but but uh one of the things that
that has happened to me over the last
number of years is I wear the same
outfit all the time
um and even when I go out casually or
I'm with my family
um like now I'll wear either something
that looks kind of similar to the you
know Blue Jacket uh blue out like I'm
essentially wearing now
um or something that's forward party
branded because uh people will recognize
me in public and then they'll uh want to
get a a selfie so what did happen is
like I I was walking around casually at
different times and then someone would
get a picture and they'd be like hey
look Andrew Yang and like you know I
wouldn't look like myself
yeah in the sense and then some people
would take note and be like hey you know
he looks different like just walking
around in sweats or you know whatever
the heck someone's like oh snap
um so I'm just sharing with you you know
like the the lived experience
um but I I think people having a brand
and a hook an identity
um and even a look like I genuinely
think it does end up driving
um associations particularly an era of
social media because uh you know like
pictures pop up everywhere yep and and
you would say you know I mean you know
you know what a Coke can looks like you
know you know you know the symbol on the
on the Mercedes I mean you know I I if
you think of yourself as a product and
in some sense we are you know I mean we
are we we not not in the sense that
people are going to buy you but in the
sense that you stand for a set of ideas
and to the extent that you help people
and reduce their cognitive processing uh
you know by by standing for something by
having a simple tagline you know by
whatever that all helps you stand out
and and become memorable which is of
course one of the things I mean you know
we how do we measure brand how do we
measure the success of advertising
campaigns we measure the success of
advertising campaigns by brand
recognition
yeah so you so you want to look you want
to be recognized you want to be and you
want that look to be associated with a
set of ideas
you know my favorite stuff to wear that
makes me feel super heroic nowadays is
my forward hoodie the forward cap
forward t-shirt so we get new arrivals
all the time if you want to do something
fun start conversation support forwards
work go to shop.forwardparty.com and
check out the swag pins cups thermoses
is that the same thing no it's not
suitcases TV sets we actually don't sell
either of those go to
shop.forwardparty.com for the funnest
ways to support forward
[Music]
foreign
how many books have you written at this
point Jeff have you been a professor for
like 20 plus years like how many books
have you written I wish 20 plus years
I've been a professor for 50 years
believe it or not anyway I've written
I've written now I'm working on my 17th
book wow that's incredible so the the
first time I wrote a book I'll relate
this experience because it might be sure
um fun so I so I started this non-profit
uh Venture for America I get a call from
a literary agent uh saying hey I think
you should write a book
um and then I think I don't have time
for that
um because I'm trying to build this
organization and so I called the agent
back and said what do you need for me to
actually write this book and he said I
need a proposal and I said well what's
that and he said uh a sample chapter how
the book's going to be sold outline I
was like oh it doesn't sound so bad
um so then I I pulled that together but
I was just pumped that anyone would ever
pay me to write a book like you know one
of the offers I got actually Jeff was
like we will not actually give you an
advance but we will was your book it was
just like a you know like we'll we'll
publish it so then I I write this book
and it does not take the World by storm
uh you know it's like uh it it but it
was additive like it it was worthwhile
it did help the org
um it wasn't you know groundbreaking or
earth-shaking or any of that jazz
um but but what was interesting is that
then when I decided to run for president
United States I call my agent uh and I'm
like hey I want to write a book about uh
the transforming economy and and why I'm
running for president
um and so then we he goes what's what's
funny is like he goes and like takes
this to Publishers and Publishers
completely do not believe that I'm going
to run for president or that it's going
to go anywhere
he was like like that I was like the
proposal it was like you know there was
one publisher
um who I still I'm so grateful to uh
where he saw potential in that in in
this book
um that became um there were normal
people and then when that came out by
the way like also did not take the World
by storm was not a big deal but then
months and months later I was on the
presidential debate stage and then they
get asked I get asked like hey if you
could give something to one of the
candidates and I just had this back and
forth with Elizabeth Warren about like
the automation manufacturing job so I
said like I'd give Senator Warren a copy
of my book
um and then I I come off stage and then
I I get like uh call my publisher being
like hey your book just hit the the New
York Times bestseller list because
and it had been out for I don't know
like a year and a half at that point so
he was like it's not normal but but I I
say this because what's funny is like I
have reluctantly followed many of the
lessons from your book without knowing
it and it's interesting you use the word
reluctant because I hear in your stories
I Andrew I hear in your stories examples
of you did uh though that you did
exactly what you should do but you
didn't embrace it so that's where you
were back to rule one get out of your
own way I've I've you wound up doing of
course things that were extraordinarily
helpful uh you know to advance your
ideas and to advance your agenda but you
didn't necessarily immediately embrace
it and so I think people listening to
this podcast should learn the lesson
which is you know pay attention to
Andrew but but don't do it reluctantly
embrace it
yeah yeah outdo me please by all means
so there are some people who are loving
this Converse some people who are
wincing were like oh like I don't know
if I I see myself in this so uh number
uh five is going to make them wince all
the more because it's everyone's least
favorite thing in the entire world uh
but rule number five uh to advance your
career and gain power is Network
relentlessly
and uh everyone hates networking and yet
so many Studies have shown that uh
networking pays off uh in a very very
big way professionally particularly when
it comes to cultivating something called
weak ties so number one why is
networking so important and number two
what are weak ties so networking is
important so the way I guess I now
describe it is the following if if
leadership or management is getting
things done through other people it
seems pretty obvious that the more other
people you know the more you'll be able
to get done I mean so that's pretty
straightforward the importance of weak
ties people tend to associate with
people that they're comfortable with and
the people that you're comfortable with
are people that you know well and are
probably similar to you in a variety of
ways maybe they work with you maybe
they're part of your family maybe
they're part of your circle of friends
the problem with people who are closely
tied to you is that they tend to know
the same people and the same things that
you do and therefore they do not bring
you much new information they don't
bring you many new contacts whatever the
people to whom you are weekly tied are
the people who can provide you
non-redundant information and
non-redundant contacts and of course
it's the non-redundant information that
is the most valuable because it's
telling you things that you don't
already know the non-redundant contacts
are the most valuable because they can
link you in to uh Circles of friends or
donors or advisors that you didn't
wouldn't already know I'm sure you have
a ton of stories from your campaign
about this we're we're in order for you
to run a successful presidential
campaign if you relied only on your
friends and family it wouldn't have gone
very far that that the part of the part
of building a campaign organization is
meeting new people to whom at the time
you met them you weren't closely tied
and many of those introductions I'm sure
came from people with whom you were
casually acquainted and as you then meet
more people you expand your sphere of
knowledge and you expand your sphere of
influence yeah I started out as friends
and family I wrote them an email and
made some calls saying hey running for
president and then some of them would
say of
and then I would say the United States
of America so so it was uh definitely a
process but you're right that the people
that ended up coming through were people
um oftentimes I did not know that well
at the get-go and that if you were going
to have any kind of success you needed
to get beyond your immediate circle
really really quickly so I I had a base
background I knew I could rely on which
is like I knew a lot of entrepreneurs I
knew people in the tech community so I
was like okay I can at least go through
that crew but you go through whatever
your crew is pretty quick
um and and so you need to to expand the
circle uh equally quickly that makes
sense I think that there are ways you
can Network that are
um more fun and less painful and and the
book talks about how if you can make it
enjoyable you're more likely to do it
but it's to try and choose networking
activities that you actually enjoy uh
and then try and uh regard it as like an
actual process with data uh that you can
hone you can improve on you can use
technology you can use spreadsheets like
all that stuff's inbounds because this
stuff is actually part of your career
that's exactly right and you know my
friend who I've put on my podcast I have
a fever on power podcast one of the
First episodes was John Levy
um who's
um who's who hosts these famous dinners
these influencer dinners and he's
written a book called you're invited and
and the your invited book has a lot of
good advice on how to put on memorable
events that people will want to come to
um and uh and and and expand your
network and he's basically you know he
tells the story of how he got into this
and he said I was in my 20s and based
basically not very distinguished and not
going very far and he said you know he
said I figured out that was probably
only going to live once and that I
wanted to surround my Myself by the most
interesting people in the world from
whom I could learn and who I could enjoy
their company and then he said you know
how in the hell am I going to get
anybody uh you know how am I going to
access these people and he figured out
putting on these events and he there was
an article written about him in the New
York Times and now he's now written this
book you're invited to talks about how
to put on these these wonderful
interesting events and some of the
principles for doing so but he then so
he now has fun so so John Levy's job is
going to dinners that that other people
host for him and their houses and that
he doesn't even pay for or doesn't pay
for very much of you know and the events
don't cost that much there's no private
Chef you actually do your own cooking
um so you know I mean so that I think
would be one thing the other book that I
always tell people about is Keith
ferazzi's book Never Eat Alone and the
title says it all don't eat alone so
from my experience one of the best ways
to build a network quickly and build a
brand and a bunch of other things and
one of the threads I've seen is that
people who host events and people who
start companies or start orgs I mean
there's a lot of overlap
um the the the training and skills
actually
end up serving you really well uh in any
context so hosting something will get
your name out there really quick I agree
with that I think that's a great idea
yes which brings us to number six which
I love and it's true is to use your
power like and the point you're making
here is like look it power is not a
finite resource where if you use it you
use it up and then you have less of it
uh it actually generally is the reverse
that if you use your power or influence
or network or whatnot it actually
enhances all of the above I mean that's
correct because people want to be
associated with success and the people
want to be associated with people who
are getting things done so to the extent
you use your power and you make things
happen then more people want to be
associated with you helping other people
is nine times out of ten like a
win-win-win uh you know like all the way
around particularly if it's making
connections if you use your network and
that way your network does get stronger
particularly if it pays off uh like it's
not like oh you do have to use a filter
like you know I mean I get I know a lot
of people so I get asked for
introductions to various people all the
time a lot of them don't make any sense
and I'm not in the habit of making
introductions that don't make any sense
but but
if it does make sense I am thrilled to
do it uh and then sometimes it pays off
where someone will get back to me later
and be like thank you so much for
introducing us because like now we're
working together or uh you know helping
each other out and you know if you think
about
you know presidents or
um you know or or Executives I mean to
the extent that Executives of companies
are able you know to successfully launch
products then then they get more power
because their brand gets built and they
become more successful and if if an
executive you know didn't use their
power to get anything done then they
would it would go away I mean with you
know this is old saying with great power
comes great responsibility I think
that's right I think with great power
comes the obligation to do something
with that power to make something happen
you know to build a business to build a
company to launch a product uh to
promulgate important ideas you know you
you you need to do something with your
power or else it'll disappear yeah you
open the book uh with this idea that for
good things to happen uh more good
people have to gain power yep that's
right
which is a you know by the way you're
doing better than my students you could
pass a test on this I could tell oh well
well thank you you know
um
it was I mean like the stuff did feel
very familiar to me I mean I you know I
am a little bit further down the road
than most of your students
and particularly because your staff had
to push you to do a lot of this stuff so
um sure I've got a whole team around me
trying to make me look good that's
another one of the joys of power is you
you have people who are trying to make
you look good at all times so number
seven uh required me to actually do a
little bit of uh thinking
um understand that once you've acquired
power what you did to get it will be
forgiven forgotten or both
I was like whoa just seems to be
suggesting that uh you know but you
uh draw a bunch of examples about how it
looked like after you get to a certain
point
um then you kind of claim a narrative in
a particular direction and most people
get on board if uh you're in that
position
um and you you use examples from both
politics and business
I think that's right I think and the
reason why I think that chapter along
with chapter one is the most important
is that because they are in fact related
to each other chapter one is getting you
know rule one is get out of your own way
and chapter and the rule seven which is
that once you've acquired power of
wealth and success people will forgive
and forget how you got there is it helps
I think people get out of their own way
to recognize I mean many people say if I
do these things in this book you know I
will be you know people will be jealous
or resentful or you know all kinds of
things and I point out that you're if
you're successful they'll be jealous or
resentful anyway and that that once you
have power many things are forgotten you
know so there's Michael Milken who's um
you know gone to jail and one day I'm
watching an Oakland A's game and he's
introduced he's in the broadcast Booth
introduces a philanthropist Martha
Stewart also went to jail I'm not
recommending that people go to jail and
her brand has never been more valuable
you know so I you know this doesn't say
you should be be you know whatever but
it does say that there is a social
reality I mean the the example with
which I open that chapter is the example
of Lindsey Graham who begins as a never
Trumper and once Trump becomes president
he is you know he's right behind him
totally yeah totally flipped and and
this apparently fascinates all these New
York Times writers and they keep asking
Lindsay you know
at one point said all these negative
things and his answer to them is you
know Donald Trump is now the president
of the United States and I want to be
relevant and so I am going to attach
myself to him and become his his new
best friend and you see this inside of
companies you see this inside of
universities you know I don't want X to
be Dean or president of the University
but when they become that you know
there's the reality and you you change
your opinion about them pretty quickly
so it it it may not make people happy
and it certainly isn't doesn't comport
with what many people would like to be
true but it is in fact true yeah and
that's the thing about your book is that
it's grounded in reality in facts and
studies uh and you just try to present
the world as it is uh you present the
way the world works as the way that you
know like here's how it works and you
have to understand it and if you want to
be a beneficiary then here are some
things you can do to be helpful uh to
yourself and to whatever organization or
group or company you're trying to help
um certainly for me there are uh all
sorts of positive things I I want to see
happen
um and well one of my frustrations
um is I have a lot of frustrations
actually but one of them is that there
there are people who want uh good things
to happen
um uh but aren't actually doing any of
the things that would be required for
any of those things to happen and so I'm
like like do you want to feel good about
yourself in a narrow
way or do you want to try and make the
good things happen because I I think we
can make the good things happen but it's
going to require like a couple different
behaviors and maybe working with people
that don't necessarily see eye to eye
with you on everything under the sun I
if you look at successful entrepreneurs
for the most part they are so focused on
executing against their Vision Steve
Jobs was like this also that they
oftentimes do not
you know pay a lot of attention uh to
anything other than accomplishing their
Vision so Steve Jobs was all about
bringing certain products to Market and
was he hard on the people who worked for
him absolutely was he always you know a
model of um you know decorum or you know
this that or the other thing of course
not and he was I think I think people
people who make things happen start with
this ambition to make things happen and
the ambition causes them to focus a lot
on the ends and less so on the means and
we can have a philosophical discussion
about means and ends but the point is
that I think you know I think I think
the the drive to make something happen
to make some change in the world to
bring a product to Market to create a
company uh you know to create a
political party to create whatever
requires a lot of ambition a lot of
drive and a lot of focus because
otherwise when you have the inevitable
setbacks
which there will be you know the the
failures and the things that don't work
and the opposition and the all this
stuff in order to in order to overcome
that you have to have
um you have to have enough Drive uh to
produce the persistence and the
resilience then I think at the end is
what really determines success uh Jeff
you've you've seen so many uh incredible
organizations rise in some cases fall
been a part of History trained
Generations you've written 17 books this
is your fourth on power uh I'm sure
you're always learning like what what do
you have coming up next what can people
look forward to from you and how can
they follow you and your work well they
can follow me by
um uh you know I have a personal home
page uh jeffreyfeffer.com they can look
at the podcast on power fefer on power
which is actually literally for
onpower.com and it's also on all of the
major uh podcast channels Apple Spotify
Etc the book I'm working on now is how
companies who pay for more than U.S more
than half of U.S health care could if
they would treat the purchase of Health
Care like they treat the purchase of
everything else actually do much to
improve the U.S health care System we
don't have to wait for Single Payer or
all these other policy reforms they
might be helpful but I don't think
they're likely to get passed and in the
meantime companies which are paying for
all this stuff uh for themselves could
actually if they would measure things
and hold people accountable could
improve a lot about health care in the
United States so that's the book I'm
currently working on the big theme to me
one of the things I try and deliver to
folks is look change is coming we might
as well make it good changes as opposed
to bad changes and I think that's
actually uh really the the lesson from
your book and your work thank you so
much for doing what you do and for
helping people live better lives you
know you talk about this and we didn't
we didn't mention it but it's important
being happy in your role professionally
and feeling like you have agency and
control leads you to be happier
healthier more content uh and and that's
what we should want for everybody that's
exactly right also leads to a longer
lifespan also leads to longer lifespan
we can uh you know uh all do what we
want for longer like Jeff here Jeff I
will see you when I'm next out west and
thank you so much Andrew thank you for
the for the privilege of being on this
show and thank you for the privilege of
uh of of knowing you it's been it's it's
really an honor getting to know you
Jeff's book again seven rules of power
is surprising but true rule advice on
how to get things done in advance your
career it's a fascinating book and you
can't help but learn a lot from it thank
you it's it's been a pleasure
foreign
[Music]